하이트
비싼데
거기에서
제 빌사남의
노크 안녕하세요 빌사남의 노크 김윤수
저희 이번에 모실 두 번째 게스트는
저희 유튜브에 많이 나왔었는데 김지
중개사를
모시겠습니다 안녕하세요
어네 안녕하세요네 어 저희 구독자
여러분들한테 간단하게 소개
부탁드리겠습니다네 안녕하세요 bsn
빌사남 중개법인 김지 중개사입니다
정말 오랜만에 와 주셨는데 바로
시작해 보면 좋을 것 같습니다 저희
사연 좀 읽어 주세요네 한번 바로
읽어 보도록 하겠습니다 안녕하세요
빌딩 시장의 갓 입문한 구독자입니다
저는 현재 현금 23억 정도 보유하고
있습니다 주식만 하다가 더 큰 자산을
불리고 싶어서 찾아 보다 빌딩 시장에
관심을 갖게 됐는데요 그러다 요즘
핫한 성수동과 많은 자산가들이 살고
있는 한남동을 눈여겨 보게 되었습니다
투자를 한다면이 둘 중에서 투자를
하고 싶은데 어떤 곳이 더 괜찮을까요
그리고 성수동은 이제 끝물 이까 저는
임대 수익보다는 시세 차익을 노리고
있습니다 어떤게 더 나을지 알려
주시면
감사하겠습니다라고 사연을 보내
주셨습니다 요즘에 이런 질문들을 좀
많이 받는 거 같아요 네 지중 사님
같은면 어디 투자하고 싶으세요 어
저라면 어떤 입지에 있느냐에 따라
달라질 것 같은데 너무 무법적인
답변이었다 이게 딱 하나 반드시
선택해야 된다 하나를 꼭 골라야
한다면 성수동을 고를 것 같습니다 아
성수동 그리고 또 이제 성수동
내에서도 있잖아요 지금 고평가되어
있는 중심 상권 주변으로 조금 확장될
가능성 있는 섹터 그이 있잖아요 예를
들면 북성 크래프톤이 젠틀 몬스터 사
들어서는 곳 인근으로 좀 저평가되어
시장에 나오는 매물들 위주로 검토를
해 볼 것 같아요 지희 중개사님 봤을
때 성수동에서 제일 좋은 곳은 어디인
거 같으세요 아무래도 연무 장길이
아닐까 싶은데 개인이 투자를
하시기에는 조금 위험 부담이 있는
곳이기 한 거 같습니다 제가 봐도
연무장 길은 지금 뭐 평당 한 2억이
넘잖아요네 그래서 사실 실질적으로 좀
투자하기 어려워서 북성 3는 아무래도
상대적으로 좀 저렴한 건물들이 꽤
있어서 거기는 그래도 막 한 1억
초반 때네 뭐 1억 원 대도 꽤
있더라고요 뭐 제가 봐도 이제
그쪽에는 소액으로 좀 투자할게 꽤
있는 거 같고 아뜰리에 길 거기는
어떻게 보세요 길 아뜰리에 길은
솔직하게 답변을 해도 될까요네 저는
아뜰리에 길은 개인의 컨텐츠가 있는
분들이 아닌 이상은 지금은 살짝 조금
지켜보시는게 좋지 않나라는 생각을
가지고 있습니다 사실 아뜰리에 길은
중공업 지역이 아니거든요 거기는 이제
이종이 건물을 더 높게 올릴 수도
없고 그 지금 상태에서 에서 최적에
사용을 해야 되는데네 제가 봤을 때는
아무래도 중공업 보다는 땅의 활용도가
좀 떨어지지 않나 이렇게 생각은 하고
있고 지금 이미 너무 비싼 거
같아요네 맞아요 저도 같은 생각입니다
이제 그쪽에도 투자할 만한게 있긴
하지만 땅의 용도 자체가 좀 다르다
뭐 이렇게 보시면 될 거 같고
한남동은 어떻게 보세요 한남동은
너무너무 좋죠 한남동은 예전부터
안정적으로 이어주던 고급 상권이자아요
그래서 한남동도서관
느낌이 있잖아요 그래서 저는 좀
확률을 높이고자 한남동에서 나올
물건이 나올 확률과 성수동에서 물건이
나올 확률을 중에서 성수동에서 물건이
좀 나올 확률이 더 높을 거라고
판단해서 성수동을 선택했습니다 저는
만약 한남동 쪽 사면은 그 꼼대
가르송 인근 이쪽이 이제 제일 좋은
거 같고 그리고 거기도 이제 북한남
있고 막 그렇잖아 한남동의 앞에도
있고 색깔이 너무 좀 달라 가지고
한남동 내에서도 그리고 성수동 비슷한
거 같아요 성수동 이제 연무장길 이냐
뭐 북성 아 아뜰리에 길이냐 이게
너무 좀 차이가 많이 나가지고네
맞아요 번뇌로 이런 질문 좀 해
볼게요 어네 요즘에 그래서 성수동이
좀 많이 비싸서네 그 송정동 많이
사잖아요 송정동은 어떻게 생각하세요
아 저는 송정동은 웬만해서는
추천드리지는 않습니다 이유는 접근성이
너무 좋지 않아요 그리고 실제로
가보시면 저는가 보시면은 왜 투자를
하시면 안 되는지 아실 거라고
생각하는데 의외로 실거래가 많이
찍히더라구요가 보시면은 공실도 되게
많고
직접 운영하는 컨텐츠가 있지 않은
이상은 건물을 채우는게 조금 어렵지
않나하는 생각이 듭니다 이게 사실
대로를 넘어가는 건 정말 엄청난
일이거든요 놀러 와서 진짜 그 대로를
넘어가는 거는 진짜 힘든 일이고
그리고 이제 상권이 연결되기는 정말
어려운 거여 가지고네 맞아요 저도
개인적으로 송정동은 왜 사는지
모르겠어요 맞아요 그리고 성수 한남
봤을 때 어디가 좀 투자 가치가 더
있어 보이세요 향후 저는 그 발전
가능성으로 본다면 성수동에 조금 더
손을 들어 주고 싶은게 아무래도 앞서
말씀드렸다시피 한남동은 좀 안정적으로
계속 유지가 되고 있던 상권이다
보니까 성장 가능성에만 초점을 두고
본다면 저는 성수동의 한표를 던지고
싶습니다 성수동의 어디가 좀 개발이
많이 될 거 같아요 오피스 지식산업
센터들 많은 북성 쪽이요 그쪽이 조금
더 발전할 가능성이 있어 보입니다
저는 그 한강변 그 재개발 아 많이
될 거 같거든요 그래서 그것도 되면은
이런 고네 거들이 좀 많이 들어올 거
같고 성수동에는 좀 개발될 만한
호재가 되게 많고 그리고 제가 요즘에
고객들한테 항상 얘기하는 건데 부동산
투자 어디에 해야 돼요 뭐 얘기 많이
하거든요 답변을 딱 하는게 부자들이
많이 사는 동네 어 맞아요 근데 정말
저도 동의합니다네 그도 사실 이게
성수동 뭐 갤러리아도 있고 뭐 아서포
있고 그 고급 주거가 많이 밀집되어
있고
한남동도서관 거기 많이 밀집되어
있잖아요 제가 봤을 때 투자 가치가
제 제 좋은 곳은 부자들이 많이
사는니다 어네 맞아요 한남동은 또
이슈 중에 하나가 한남 뉴타운
있잖아요네 그건 좀 어떻게 보세요 어
너무 좋죠 성수에 성수 전략
정비구역이 있다면 한남동에
한남뉴타운이 있는 거잖아요 고급 주거
세대 배우를 가지고 있는 상권이며
그들이 그 상권 내에서 계속 소비를
해 줄 거라는 그런 믿음이 있잖아요
그래서 아무래도 상권이 쉽게 죽지
않을 거라는 그런 생각이 있어서 그런
면에서도 조금 좋은 거 같습니다 비판
질문을 하자면 한남 뉴타운에 투자하는
건 어떻게 생각하세요 아 잘 알아보고
투자를 하셔야 하지 않을까 뭐 좋다
좋다 하고 무작정 투자하는 건 아니지
않을까요 저는 개인적으로는 돈이
묶인다 그 생각하거든요 내 의지와
상관없이 개발이 언제 되는지도
모르고네 이해 관계인이 너무 많아서
사실 그런 투자는 리스크가 있다라고
생각해서 한남 뉴타운에 투자하시는
분들 되게 많거든요 생각 꼭 실거래
찍히는 것도 있더라고요 한남 뉴타운은
제 개인적인 생각에 이해 관계인이
많고 돈이 묶기는 것 좋 좋지 않다
이렇게 생각을 하고 있습니다 제가 그
fmb 하시는 분들 많이 만나거든요
성수동이 그 한남동에 장사하고 계신
분 고객인데 얘기를 들어보면 성수동이
사람이 많아요 진짜 많이 오는데
실질적으로 돈은 안 쓴대요 아네
맞아요 저도 그거 본 적 있어요 팝업
스토어 때문에 사람들이 엄청 많이
몰려 오긴 하지만 실질적으로 장사를
해보면 남는게 없다라는 얘기를 많이
듣거든요 근데 반면에 한남동은
그거보다 괜찮대요네 객단가도 조금
성수동에 비해서 좀 높은 변으로
이루어져 있는 거 같고 그래서 그런
점에 있어서는 한남동이 좀 더 좋지
않나 싶기는 하지만 주차도 대부분
한남동은 다 차다고 맞아요 그신 거
성수동은 아 성수동이 주차가 더
괜찮구나 저는 외국인 친구가 있다거나
외국에서 어떤 손님이 오신다고 하시면
한남동을 하루 코스로 추천을 좀 많이
드릴 수 있을 것 같아요 그랜드
아트에서 묵으시면서 문화 공간에서
공연과 예술도 즐기시고 배고프면 가서
밥도 먹고 카페도 가시고 또 쇼핑하고
싶으면 쇼핑도 하실 수 있잖아요 근데
반면에 성수동으로 가서 좀 생각을
해보자 하면 연무장길 팝업 조금
즐기다가 배고픔에 좀 먹고 뭔가
끝나는 느낌인 거 같아서 외국인에서
뭔가 손님이 오시거나 지인이 온다면
한남동을 더 추천할 것 같긴 합니다
하이
비싼데
거기네 얘기해봤는데 혹시 구독자
여러분들 중에 궁금한 얘기가 있다라고
하면은 댓글 남겨 주시거나 아니면
이메일 보내 주시면 저희가 다음번
촬영할 때 주제로 사용하도록
하겠습니다네 여기까지 하겠습니다
안녕녕 똑똑
[음악]